thank you very much and thank you for
joining our talk today on making fake
data generators for open source data
science projects my name is jennifer
hall i'm a senior data scientist at the
nhsai lab and i'm joined by my colleague
matthew cooper who's also a senior data
scientist at the nhs ai lab
so what we're going to be covering today
we're going to look at how we use fake
data generators why they're good for our
projects
how you can implement a fake data
generator
what is synthetic data and our recent
work on synthetic data
so first the nhs ai lab skunk works team
the nhs ai lab is part of the nhs
transformation directorate
it was formed
to support the safe ethical adoption of
ai in the nhs and it's made up of a
number of programmes including
regulation
ethics imaging and the skunk quick
scheme which we're a part of
and the term skunk works
came from lock martin in the 1940s which
looks at really short experimental
projects and that's what we do in the
skunkworks team
we focus on very small rapid agile
experimentation looking at applications
direct applications with the nhs
with ai technology
we're a small team that's also that's
always trying to find initial ways in
which the ai can support existing
existing solutions and help solve
problems across the nhs
a big part of what we do is actually try
to share our learnings from the
experimentation that we do and to do
that we publish case studies and we also
open source code
and a big part of sharing those
learnings was the ability for people to
interact with that code and actually
understand how it works and that's where
the importance of actually being able to
have fake data in our repos so people
could pass and pass the data through the
models could interact with what we had
built became so important and we saw
that really with our first project that
we um open source which is looking at
patients who long stay in hospital and
we were actually looking at if we can
predict our emission how long a patient
was going to stay
in hospital
so before we get too much into the
detail of that i'm going to share a
definition
of what we actually mean by a fake data
generator
so a fake data generator is a data set
generated at random with the purpose of
testing code the data set will contain
the same number of fields and same data
types as the original data but will not
replicate any relationships or patterns
found in the original data set so for
example the data that was originally
used to train a data data science model
um
isn't isn't isn't isn't using this and
the fake data is generated independently
of the original data set
um
one of the reasons why we can't
anonymize the set is because of
well the data that we deal with is very
sensitive
um
we're dealing with health data so we
can't really publish that even if we
anonymized it would have to go through a
lot of approval
and rightly so in terms of information
governance making sure that we've
covered across everything by gdpr by
having fake data generators it allows us
to be a lot more open in terms of what
we can share
fab so why do we need a fake data
generator which kind of answers your
question so thank you for leading me on
nicely to the next slide
um
so
when
gloucestershire applied augusta
hospitals applied
last year about their idea about whether
we can predict patients who can long
stay
and that's when when you say long stay
we mean patients who stay over 21 days
in hospital
it was a really important problem that
we knew
that would affect other trust and that
if we
um this project could really benefit
other trusts across the nhs
um prolonged stays in hospital can be um
bad for patients especially those who
are frail and elderly and there's one
journal that reported that 10 10 extra
days in hostel can be a deterioration of
about 10 years especially in patients
who are elderly
so what we wanted to do was have a proof
of concept which explored whether or not
we could predict how long a patient was
going to stay in hospital
and then from that we can show that to
frontline staff and then we can look at
how patients can have their
care tailored
and personalized so they might not have
to stay so long in hospital
and why this was needed was when we
published the code a lot of trust
started to reach out to us and saying we
have a similar problem we'd love to to
try and interact with some of this code
but we can't but as to your point we
couldn't share the data
so why we needed it was though we could
properly test the code when the real
data was not available so we opened it
up and anyone can have a go and have a
look
and and test what we had done it
improves learning and understanding um
as users are able to step through step
by step
and
and also understand actually how the
data is structured in terms of data
types um some examples of what would be
then in terms of like string length
and character length and also promotes
transparency and is a really interactive
way in which people just don't have to
read the code but they can properly
engage with it and run it
so that's kind of the background and the
context of why we're doing this and why
we think it's important i'm going to
hand over to matthew who's going to talk
through a bit more about the
practicalities of how you put one
together
thank you
[Applause]
thanks very much jennifer so i'm now
talked a little bit about motivations
why you might want to generate fake data
i'm going to sort of talk about uh some
of the practicalities like we just
mentioned so we're going to start off
looking at the key components that you
might um you might need if you want to
generate some fake data and these are
relatively straightforward um and sort
of i guess by looking at the example
that you've got here which is taken from
the long stays work we were just talking
about
um they sort of read themselves off the
slide really so the first one obviously
is you need to know what columns you
want to generate
and here we sort of call that column
names you need to be able to define
exactly what columns you want to
be generated in your fake data set
going hand in hand with that you need to
know what type of data you want to go in
those columns so and don't want to just
randomly put any type of data across all
the columns you need to specify um in
particular fields and specific data
types
building off of that for where you've
got categorical data types and the fake
data generator needs to know what the
fake category options are so you need to
specify those as well
and we'll come on to sort of how you
might do that and maybe the way you
might do it but in this middle column
you can see that on the screen
and finally obviously you need to know
quite how much fake data you need to
generate in our example here it's a
tabular data so it's the number of rows
that you would produce
so using those four things you can then
go ahead and start to build out a
fake data sort of pipeline
so again pretty straightforward but what
you start with is on the left hand side
the uh
the number of rows that you're gonna
generate as well as the file name that
you want to save the file down as
and you combine that with the list of
field names that we're just talking
about and together with those you
produce an empty data frame nice and
simple so you've got a empty grid that
you're gonna then populate with your
fake data
moving through to the second step um you
start
with uh generating your fake data in the
in the categorical fields so going back
to our list of fake category options
that we mentioned before you go through
and randomly choose a fake category
option for each row in each column and
you're going to generate the fake data
for
once that's done we then move on to
numeric and date fields which again are
just generated randomly um
you might want to set a range of
a range for those of those fields or
generate them completely randomly
depending on what your motivation your
fake data is
once that's complete yeah fake data is
generated so it's nice and simple
building off of that we want to share
some of the best practices and some
things you might want to think about if
you're going to be generating fake data
these build on the things that jennifer
was mentioning a little bit earlier but
we wanted to emphasize them so one of
the key ones in terms of best practices
is to try and ensure that any fake data
that you generate is obviously fake um
that might sound like a bit obvious
statement but the point here is that the
purpose of fake data is to test code not
to try and produce results that mean
something
um particularly in the healthcare
context
going back to your question from before
it's important that if someone picked up
a data set that was fake they didn't
look they couldn't look at it and
suspect that it actually was patient
data that could be problematic so it
needs to be really clear that the data
set if someone opened it with no other
context having never seen the code or
the project before and that it was fake
and all its purpose was was to test the
kind of
plumbing of the code if you like
related to that it's we think important
not to over complicate the generation of
the fake data so the idea again i'm
emphasizing this a lot is to test the
plumbing of the code so you don't want
your fake data to try and replicate any
of the relationships that are in the
real data it's purely there to feed
through your code and produce an output
just to test that it all works so it
doesn't need to be any more complicated
than just randomly populating the fields
and finally again you'll notice these
best practices all sort of related you
need to be really clear in your
documentation about what the purpose of
the data generator is so on the right uh
top right there's a sort of snippet from
our one of our piece of documentation
which might be a bit small on this
screen
but it basically emphasizes what you
should use the fake data for so testing
plumbing testing code working out how a
piece of code works and what you
shouldn't use it for so don't try and
use it produce model artifacts or
predictions don't use it in real world
settings
and don't use it to try and
to try and test the performance of your
model because it just doesn't make sense
relate to that let's move on to the
considerations that you might want to
think about so things that you might
want to bear in mind when you're
generating fake data so it should be
noted that we're really clear about this
is that fake data will usually produce
meaningless results in some cases most
cases probably so in classification
models predictions forecasts you'd
expect fake data to produce results that
don't make any sense
and again that feeds into the meaning
and the purpose of using fake data is
purely practical not to test performance
on the flip side there is a bit of a
balance between making data clearly fake
and the output of your fake data
generator still being understandable um
so as an example for all the categorical
fields you could just fill them all with
completely random strings but that might
not help anyone with understanding what
the input data set should be
so maybe a better practice and the
middle column there you can see that for
a column that's showing admission method
there's test admission method a method b
and a null value so that says to someone
here's the possible sorts of values you
might expect to see in here and likewise
in the date which i think is on the far
right hand side
the dates look like dates but they're
set really far in the future or in the
past so it's clear that it's a date but
it's not um contemporary
so as jennifer mentioned um scriptworks
projects that we produced within the
team include fake data generators as
standard now and we've delivered a
number of different open source projects
which include fake data generators so um
there's a long story stratification one
which is one we've been talking about
here
and which uses a tabular data set and
there's a project that looks at bed
allocation so when someone gets admitted
to hospital where they should be placed
and on what ward they should be admitted
onto so that needed fake data around
hospitals and admissions
and then we've also done a project
looking at ct scan alignment a little
bit different one from those top two i
needed images the idea and the approach
was similar but we produced um white
noise images that are over the right
size and resolution um so that again you
could test the code but without any
results
it's worth noting and again for this
presentation some alternatives um that
you might might consider if you were
thinking of using fake data big data is
just one way of getting data out to and
released alongside your code um so there
are some alternatives i guess we can
circle up to the question again but you
could use real data this is really
really industry and sensitivity
dependent and so for healthcare this
isn't an option
but depending on where you work it might
be
the next one is repurposing an open an
existing open source data set so you
might find that you could go and find a
piece of data that's already there that
serves most of the purposes of what you
need maybe has the same field types some
similar names similar similar idea you
could take that and maybe wrangle it a
little bit and use that to feed into
your model
to demonstrate how someone might might
use your code
and finally which we'll come on to in a
second um you could generate some
synthetic data this isn't
straightforward and isn't a sort of um
it doesn't address all the problems that
there are with fake data um but it's
something that might be considered as an
improvement on
me on fake data
so why would you use synthetic data so
the main problem as we've sort of
touched on in this presentation so far
is that fake data limits capabilities
what you can do with a code release
it stops you from assessing model
performance and understanding exactly
how well the model works
so the big benefit of using something
like synthetic data is that it enables
users to understand how well your model
works and maybe see a more
realistic output from your model rather
than just something that is a jumbled
set from the from the fake data you've
put in however there's substantial
challenges associated with fake data as
well so information governance is a big
thing working in healthcare and using
synthetic data only mitigates some of
the information governance challenges um
there's still information governance
associated with synthetic data
so if that's a problem with your real
data uh synthetic data might not solve
it
bottom two are kind of interlinked so
generating and evaluating synthetic that
can be quite tricky and there isn't
really any standards for evaluating
synthetic data so it can be quite
difficult to know if what you've
produced is good or works or is
appropriate
we in the schoolworks team were
interested in exploring synthetic data
and an opportunity came up working with
the analytics unit at the nhs um and
they were looking to undertake a
specific project which needed a nice
varied rich set of synthetic data
and also the scope works team supported
them by developing a pipeline which
we're going to explain in the rest of
this presentation to produce data that
met their needs um we used a synthetic
data generation model called synth vae
which you can see details on the right
hand side
that was generated by the analytics unit
um and we took our model and fitted it
into a reusable pipeline um that went
end-to-end to generate and evaluate
synthetic data
so again this nice sort of approach
approach diagram we started this was
kind of what we planned to do so we
wanted to take an existing open source
data set so using that concept that i
mentioned earlier we ideally want it to
be healthcare oriented
we're going to pre-process it into a
structure that was useful to us we're
then going to take synthe that's the
synthetic data generation model train it
generate some synthetic data with it and
then the biggest and i guess most
substantially useful part was we were
going to take a range of existing
metrics for evaluating synthetic data
and put them into a report that reported
on privacy quality and utility
and the output was going to be
the synthetic data a report and some
nice visualizations to summarize um what
we found about the data
so in terms of sourcing training data
there's obviously loads of data sets
synthvae was originally
sort of created using the pycoc support
data set
they wanted in the analytics unit they
wanted more categorical columns and more
date time fields
so we chose mimic 3 which is an open
source intensive care unit electronic
health records data set from the us
on the right hand side you can see sort
of like a diagram showing how it's
structured and the size and variety of
mimic three meant that we could create a
single file from lots of different
tables i think there's about 25 tables
within it and so we could pick and
choose exactly what we wanted to get a
data set that fitted our needs
i then wanted to touch briefly before
handing back to jennifer about what the
model looks like so synthe as the name
suggests is a variational auto encoder i
won't dwell on this for too long but the
way it works is you put an input into it
you train the weights in the encoder and
the decoder which creates a latent space
um and you initially train the model to
try and reproduce your input data
and then you can feed in
random data at the input and that
produces output data that looks like
your training data originally
so i'll hand back to jennifer to talk
about
the evaluation stage of the project
[Applause]
thank you matt so i'm going to talk
about how we evaluate synthetic data how
do we make sure
that what the output is looks it looks
good
um and we classify sort of evaluations
to three different concepts so we have
utility
quality and
privacy so utility
is about what the data is actually going
to be used for so we need to think about
what the purpose is is it going to be
data that we're going to give to someone
who wants to try and get insights in
terms of correlations between different
variables or is it someone who just
wants to test whether data can flow
through an app so there's different
levels in which
the quality is needed which actually
feeds into the next one which is about
quality and is the date is the synthetic
data a good enough representation
of the original data to do the work that
we want to do
so how much ground truth is still in
that synthetic data
and i'm going to talk a little bit more
about some of the tests in a second
about how we actually look and measure
some of the quality and the last one is
privacy which is again incredibly
important especially in healthcare so
how do we make sure the synthetic data
isn't giving anything away with the
original data how do we make sure that
now there's no leakage in terms from the
original data set and it's particularly
important so who's going to have access
to that data set and i think to the
first question
you know if it's going to be up to
everyone are you going to have to go
through some kind of approval process to
be able to access that data there's all
these things that we need to think about
before actually generating the data
and here are some metrics that we
actually included in our synthetic data
repo
this isn't all of them but this is some
of the high level ones so we have things
like collision analysis so we look to
see whether the rows in the synthetic
data set are appearing in the real data
so we make sure that the data is
matching or not matching depending on on
your purpose um
we also have correlation analysis so we
look at
how different fields within each data
set are correlating so make sure that
for example if you wanted a high quality
data set that you make sure that the
correlations are very similar between
fields and variables in each data set um
we look at the gower distance so we look
at evaluating the gall distance and
that's looking at how similar the data
sets are
we look at principal component analysis
and that's looking that helps us to
understand kind of the patterns
in the data and the different groupings
and and the variants
we also look at propensity testing and
that's when we combine the synthetic and
real data sets together and we do a very
simple model
in terms of predicting
um
who's in the synthetic data set and
who's in the real data set and see
whether how well the model can
distinguish between those two sets
and we have
very high high level statistical
distribution so like means average
and data distributions as well just to
get an overview in terms of what's going
on in the data
as well as included we actually
used sdv which is a really good
python package it's the it's the thin
static data vault in this package there
are various
models that you can use to synthesize
data and they also have their own
valuation
function which we which we incorporated
which has even more tests and they've
got loads of information on the website
about those tests and how to use them
so i definitely recommend checking that
out if you're interested in synthetic
data to learn anything i mean there
could be risk but there will be an auto
encoder that the automatic might just
memorize some patterns right do you run
if you test in the end to see that they
know no records that could be identified
possibly just because of the um
yeah so um
in terms of what we do with that so we
haven't actually published any synthetic
data from our team um but if we were
going to look at privacy checks that'd
be absolutely one thing that we would
check and we would have to make sure
in terms of like information governance
who can actually access that data
so yeah so we'll absolutely make sure
you know that that's part of the
collision analysis is that we would make
sure that records wouldn't be appearing
in the synthetic data that were in the
real data
and there's also a range of other
privacy techniques that you can do that
the analytics unit in the transformation
directorate are actually exploring as
well
so
matt talked through how we got the data
we've now synthesized the data we've now
checked our data
and now it's all about joining up so how
do we join it all together
we use the package called kedrow which
is an open source
python
pipelining tool and the reason why we
did the pipeline is because we wanted to
make this as reusable as possible
we do want people to use the code and
interact with the code and kedra offers
us a good way to make the code reusable
for other
for people who are interested
so you can see the pipeline here that
matt spoke through a couple of slides
ago and you can see that kedro kedron
com encompasses sort of the middle part
so um looking at the pre-processing of
the data the training and the evaluation
of the data
cadre allows us to have a config file
which is important so the user can set
their own settings and know where to set
their settings so none of that is buried
in the code that can be adapted by the
user
we also
have smaller pipelines so if you just
wanted to run the evaluation pipeline
because you have your own model you can
do that equally if you just wanted to
run the training of the model you can do
that as well so kejr allows us to be
quite adaptable in that sense you don't
have to run the whole pipeline and the
whole pipeline can be around with just
one line of code which makes it
incredibly accessible once you have the
data
it also allows us to visualize the
pipelines and i think that's really key
in terms of understanding what's
actually happening in terms of a
learning tool as well that you can
really interact with that and kedroviz
is really helpful to really understand
where the data is flowing um and where
and um matthew and i both worked on this
project collaboratively and having a
framework like kedro allows us to join
up different parts of our code really
easily and managed managed to make it
flow
really well
so where are we now so um we have a case
study already released on our website so
um please check that out if you're
interested in finding out more um we are
going to be open sourcing our code very
shortly um so please check that out when
that's ready um and synthvae is
currently being developed by um
analytics unit um and one of the phd
interns that's currently looking at that
so um please keep an eye out for more
exciting updates
um i'd like to thank you for joining our
talk today
and taking the time to listen to us if
you'd like to find out more information
please visit our website also if you
have any questions please feel free to
email us but thank you very much
[Applause]
we want to do a bit of q a or
uh yeah thanks very great talk um i have
uh two questions first um
in the fake data
uh and not for uh
actually training models or anything
just just for evaluating whether your
code works um
i know that from personal experience
that uh healthcare data has lots of
missing data so drug administrations or
you know times where the
someone isn't being checked
do you accommodate for that in building
fake data if so how broadly
and the second question is um
when you're building synthetic data sets
how do you
kind of match up the
the
[Music]
statistical properties of the um
with the data set without
giving away too much of the so how do
you control how much of the
original character of the dataset you
capture in your synthetic data
how can you sort of go about tweaking it
so that you make sure that you
can give away just enough to get the job
done but not too much
um which i'll take the first one yeah
i'll take the first question and matthew
take the second um so the first question
about missing data so um what we do in
in the repo and you can have a look at
the long stay repo as an example is that
we have a json file
that's got some example categories in it
and in there if you wanted to and some
of some of the data that we had didn't
have extensively but if you wanted you
could put missing values
or null values
in one of those examples and then what
happens is when the fake data generator
has been generated
um
the
it will literally just take a random
sample of each of those different
categories so you would have missing
data if you included it in your list for
that particular field the missing data
will appear and that's when you can
experiment in terms of how the code
would deal with missing data
um
and you can adapt that to however you
want it to be so if you wanted to see
what would happen if i put a number in a
string field for example because that
sometimes happens you could do that and
the fake generator would read from that
list put in the number
and then you can experiment with that
i'll hand over to matthew for the second
part
yeah so
the question about the
i guess the it's one of the big
challenges with synthetic data is that
balance and that's what the kind of the
privacy quality utility kind of
questions about um so i think
there's always the challenge of
if you want the data set to be as open
as you can you're going to have to
sacrifice quality utility because what
makes what's kind of central to quality
utility is that reproducing the original
data set really well um you can help to
minimize the risks by doing things like
collision analysis and the gower
distance so you can
if you're seeing uh in your statistical
test and the other metrics that
it's a good reproduction but you haven't
directly reproduced records or um you
don't have records that are really close
to the original records you maybe could
have a conversation about whether or not
you're satisfied with that but it's
really there isn't one answer of this is
what you do and this and this means that
you get a really useful data set that
will get past all of the you know we'll
we'll meet all the required approvals
regulation etcetera um it's a really
open question and that doesn't really
help necessarily but it's a balancing
act at all times you need to speak with
stakeholders to understand what's
important what isn't important and then
make a decision about
about what the outcome should be
um sorry
do you ever need and that was really
good i really enjoyed that sorry
the a need for
a step where like production data
is always pure filth
people have
smart quotes for example people have
pasted from their case notes the smart
quotes in word and
everyone's waiting for the app to go
live and it blows up because it reads a
smart quote and 500. do you have a step
or a need for
for that kind of
injecting those you know data gremlins
or
horribleness in the
in the data yeah i know what you mean um
i think so at the moment we don't do
that with fake data but i think
it could be useful extension although
i
i guess it depends what you're using
fake data for if the intention is to
stretch you know to try and test that
your tool works for all different um
sort of edge cases like that i guess
then you can adapt your fake data
generator to do that i guess the angle
we are coming or coming out from was
putting some data out there that
demonstrates how the pipeline works end
to end broadly um so that someone could
go away and use it so
in our work we probably don't really
have a need for that at the moment but i
can definitely see where it would be
useful for sure
hi thanks very much for your talk um i
was just wondering how well the
synthetic data works in terms of if you
have lots of data across different
tables like in cprd and and data sources
like that how well does it preserve
those sort of like inter-table
relationships
between events and like patients or
whatever
yeah i think it really depends on the
model that you use ultimately and the
model that we ended up using
performed okay
again i think it comes back to this
privacy quality utility sort of balance
um in that if you want it to really
preserve um the balance of you know they
preserve the the relationships across
those tables that sacrifices to be made
elsewhere and there's definitely some
models that do it better than others
whereas there's other models that
prioritize privacy and maybe sacrifice
that balance so i think in our case it
performed so-so
yeah
thanks
hi thanks uh very great talk um about
the data itself uh what were you able to
uh use it for other than predicting a
better allocation i think it was and
length of stay
and more as a sort of policy question
second part of the question already um
how futile is it to be working on
something like this
considering that at the end of the day
it's just lack of funding for the nhs
and
as in so to formulate that were this to
be fully automated and where it's been
like really smooth you know um
is is sort of
the nhs being dragged through the mud
how much how much is going to help
basically
so
i think there's definitely a place for
fake and synthetic data
anyway broadly not just not just in the
nhs generally because it improves
accessibility to data that might not
otherwise be available so i don't think
it's
i think it's a good use of time and
effort because
it improves access to all sorts of
things like for example on the long
stays project we've got a data set
internet we've been working on but we
couldn't release that because it's
patient records so
it improves accessibility to what we've
done from other trusts who have their
own internal data sets
that they could work on but
if we just release the code maybe they
wouldn't know exactly how a field was
generated or exactly the name of a field
a fairly basic example but
that would help to improve their
understanding
i don't know if that answers your
question necessarily i think it is a
useful use of our time and we've had
good feedback on providing fake data we
did do a few projects where we didn't
have any data with it and the feedback
was not too sure how we can run this um
so by doing that we feel like we've
added an extra an extra element to our
to our projects
hi uh apologize at the beginning so
sorry you did already mention this have
you come across the privacy preserving
gan approach to generating synthetic
data
i think we so
i think the analytics unit have tried
that i know that the synthe um
model had a um differential privacy
feature that was built on it we didn't
use that for this because it was sort of
a bit more of a proven the end-to-end
side of things um
but i think
a big part of the a useful next step in
this work would be going through and
looking at how different models
performed in this
in this kind of setup so that you could
maybe use evaluation report to
compare the outputs from different
models for the same data set you know
across wise that isn't something that
we've done here um but i think
it
a framework like this would provide um a
way of comparing those so looking at how
the privacy has been
been been preserved in the in from the
gann versus synthia as an example yeah
it does seem a bit too good to be
through because it's getting the it's
going to learn the trends from somewhere
but the the promise of that paper this
was back when i was doing excellent
based tracking of data to see if we
could detect an abnormality is you could
generate as as long as you want amount
of data that has all the traits in it
and preserves privacy it's like
win-win-win theoretically i'm a bit very
skeptic on this um i feel your pain i
did some stuff with these scottish
healthcare data and i had graphs that i
would love to show people but the end
was less than five so i couldn't i was
like this is so irritating
i can show you the events of kidney
failure but i can't show you the graph i
can just say that i can do it um so it's
a very frustrating thing one one other
question
is there a point where the ethical
consideration is outweighed by the need
for doing good so you might have
something that breaks the privacy but it
is valuable to do it i'll give you my
example from was it 23andme they
discovered a 100 penetrant variant of
huntington's disease because somebody
had an
absurdly long repeat sequence that even
their really insensitive um scanning
came up with it and they were like but
we don't have the patient's consent it's
not a patient but the person's consent
to tell them that they have hundreds of
disease because that was abs certainly
wrong repeat sequence um is there a
point where this would outweigh that
um i think it's quite a difficult
question um
and i think
i don't know is the answer i don't want
to plan on the answer either way i think
if something like that came up in our
work it would be a conversation to have
with the people who uh work on ethics
within the ar lab and on regulations and
that's something to understand what the
best path would be
i guess it could be something that came
up but it's not something we've
encountered thanks very much
thank you for the talk
i would like to ask uh a bit about the
role of fake as opposed to synthetic
data so uh is there a particular use
case where fake is superior other than
privacy limits us from from using the
other kind of data
and also uh
let's follow up
do you think there is a place for
manually generated data or partially
partially manually generated data
combined with random inputs maybe
i'm sorry can you just repeat the
question please yeah so
when do we want fake data as opposed to
synthetic data is it just when privacy
prevents us from using the other one or
is there any other case oh yeah thank
you
um
no that is a good question so
at the moment where we are with
synthetic data there's still so much
more we need to understand especially
around privacy
and like i mentioned the analytics unit
is doing quite a lot of work in this at
the moment
and that's kind of the reason why we
have that separation between the
synthetic data and the fake data the
fake data has has never been exposed
to the real data set
the any patterns in it are completely
random it's generated every single time
that someone someone runs it
um
and that way we can be fully confident
that
that there's no privacy because it's not
real data it's just there's nothing in
there
um
whereas with synthetic data to someone's
point earlier
there is potential because it has seen
the real data
so for us at the moment the fake data
allows us to publish
with the synthetic data there's still so
much more we need to understand
before before we can start
maybe interchanging them but there's so
much more work that needs to be done
before
before we can start publishing it or
given access
we're just not quite there yet so that's
kind of the difference i hope that
answers your question
hi nick radcliffe from stochastic
solutions and smart data foundry i
wonder if i could add a response to that
actually i was working synthetic data i
guess the other case where i'd say that
fake data as it's being described can be
superior
is when what you're primarily doing is
testing robustness of software because
it's much easier to put really
destructive you know massive outliers
really bad data and stuff i mean you
might think that real data sets and nhs
data and so on is bad but you can you
can put even worse stuff in fake data
really easily so it's the same as sort
of fuzzing approach to
testing software so that's the other
case where i'd say it can literally be
superior to use fake data
thank you
thank you
okay so we've got maybe one minute i
don't know if you wanted to have any
closing thoughts or um
just a very quick question so um i like
that's when you show that the way the
metric you are using there are many of
those probably are more i wondering in
if you are not satisfied or you want a
better stuff how do you handle this with
with your model just you have to change
model or just you play with the
parameters
because you i think you should just show
one model or but
you plan to have more of them or you
think that is enough is just playing
with you know parameters or something or
i might hand this one over to you matt
yeah so i think um what we're gonna be
publishing uses one model but there's
nothing to stop you going away and
because it's written in kedrow you could
go and adapt the code say okay i want to
see the output of this model but also i
want to run it with another model and
that would enable you to compare like
for like um i think the intention of the
pipeline is to kind of show a um
high-level overview of how good the
synthetic data is that that's been
generated
and if you weren't satisfied you could
maybe go away and do a bit more analysis
to try and understand exactly where the
problems are because some of the metrics
and the approaches give a you know an
idea of the problem but might not say
okay the problem is in this field or you
know et cetera et cetera and so i think
going away and investigating then might
inform you whether or not there's high
parameter tweaks you could do or choose
a whole model all together um and then
hopefully the pipeline enables that
swapping in and out to try and help you
get the best result
that you're after
you